- C'est possible de limiter la
hausse température à 1,5 degrés
Celsius.
- La crise climatique, elle,
ne fait que s'accélérer.
- Mais il faut faire des choix
radicaux.
- Le Canada va devoir faire des
choix difficiles.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Dans le contexte où on a vu
cet été, tous ces phénomènes
météorologiques vraiment très
alarmants, extrêmes, à quel
point cette COP 26, cette grande
conférence est importante?
ANNIE CHALOUX, prof. agrégée
École politique appliquée
Université de Sherbrooke
- La conférence de Glasgow est
une conférence qui est très,
très attendue, parce qu'on est
cinq ans après la mise en oeuvre
de l'accord de Paris, l'entrée
en vigueur. Et c'est cette année
où les Etats doivent revenir à
la table avec le rehaussement de
leurs ambitions. Donc, présenter
ce qu'ils ont fait, mais aussi
ce qu'ils s'engagent à faire
de plus pour qu'éventuellement,
on atteigne les objectifs fixés
par l'accord de Paris.
EDDY PEREZ
Réseau action climat Canada
- Un tiers des petits États
insulaires ne pourront pas
participer. Ce sont les pays
qui, eux, vivent les pires
conséquences des changements
climatiques et qui ne seront
pas présents pour adopter les
grandes décisions de la COP 26.
Et donc, si la COP devait être
un lieu équitable pour que les
nations s'entendent sur les
priorités climatiques, cette
fois-ci, ça ne le sera pas.
Et donc ça va jouer quand même
un rôle important sur le contenu
de l'accord.
- Selon vous, quel est le grand
enjeu, la grande question qui va
nous tenir occupés pendant deux
semaines.
- C'est de faire tout ce qu'on
peut pour garder l'objectif de
limitation de la température à
1,5 degrés Celsius à portée de
la main, et donc de changer un
peu la façon dont on parle des
grands objectifs climatiques.
Ce n'est plus la cible de chaque
Etat qui compte. C'est le 1,5
comme cible principale qu'il
faut garder en tête et accélérer
le pas le plus possible pour que
d'ici les dix prochaines années,
on puisse être en voie de
limiter la hausse de la
température à 1,5 degrés
Celsius.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Je pense que ce qui se
distingue le plus, c'est
vraiment celui du rehaussement
de l'ambition des Etats, parce
que le dernier rapport du GIEC,
paru en août dernier,
nous montre qu'on doit agir
maintenant, qu'on doit arrêter
de voir des cibles simplement
à long terme ou à moyen terme,
mais que dès maintenant,
les Etats doivent montrer tout
ce qu'ils peuvent mettre sur
la table pour réellement faire
une différence. Ça va être de
remettre en question le secteur
des énergies fossiles.
Ça va être de mettre fin aux
subventions aux carburants
fossiles. Ça va être de voir
comment on peut ré-arrimer
le secteur des transports pour
qu'il soit en phase avec la
lutte contre les changements
climatiques.
- Justement, est-ce que ce n'est
pas ça l'éléphant dans la pièce,
un peu, les énergies fossiles?
- Tout à fait. Le secteur
des énergies fossiles, c'est
le grand enjeu qu'on doit...
qu'on doit répondre maintenant.
Si on veut espérer atteindre
nos objectifs pour 2030 et 2050,
on doit freiner maintenant
toute nouvelle construction
d'infrastructures qui permettent
la production ou le transport
des hydrocarbures. Donc, dans le
contexte canadien, ça voudrait
dire remettre en question un
projet comme Trans Mountain.
Ça veut dire ne plus accepter
de nouveaux projets de forage.
Donc c'est des choix qui sont
très difficiles, mais qui
doivent être faits.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Notre propre régulateur
canadien de l'énergie projette
en fait une expansion de
l'énergie fossile jusqu'en 2050.
Donc il y a une discordance
entre les approches et c'est
ce qui fait, en fait, que
la contribution du Canada à
la COP 26 ne demeure pas tant
crédible. Elle est crédible,
peut-être sur papier.
Le vrai test, qui est celui de
la réduction des gaz à effet de
serre, le Canada demeure encore
derrière d'autres grands États.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Et à cet objectif de réduction
des gaz à effet de serre,
d'augmenter les ambitions des
pays, où est-ce que ça va
accrocher, d'après vous?
- Ça va accrocher à plusieurs
niveaux. Le premier, c'est quand
on parle de rehausser le niveau
d'ambition, bien ça veut aussi
dire rehausser le niveau
d'ambition sur la question
du financement, par exemple.
Les pays s'étaient engagés, dans
le cadre de l'accord de Paris, à
avoir un plancher de financement
à la hauteur de 100 milliards$
par année à compter de 2020.
Et en ce moment, les chiffres
nous montrent qu'on n'est pas
encore là.
- Chaque État a son
interprétation sur ce que ça
veut dire d'accélérer l'action
climatique. Et donc, on aura
évidemment les pays riches
qui vont vouloir demander aux
économies émergentes d'en faire
davantage. Et de l'autre côté,
les économies émergentes vont
dire : mais qu'est-ce que vous
nous donnez, en fait, pour qu'on
puisse vraiment croire que vous
êtes sérieux dans votre
engagement? Les 100 milliards,
c'est un engagement symbolique.
Ça fait 12 ans que les pays
riches eux-mêmes se sont engagés
à octroyer 100 milliards $ pour
l'atténuation et l'adaptation
au changement climatique.
On sait aujourd'hui que les pays
riches ne pourront pas mobiliser
100 milliards en 2020 et en
2021, et peut-être même en 2022.
Donc, la question des 100
milliards, c'est une question de
confiance, et c'est au coeur
même de ce qui pourrait arriver
à Glasgow. Pourquoi? Parce que
sans confiance, sans cette
volonté de coopération, c'est
très difficile d'atteindre de
grands objectifs pour accroître
l'ambition entre États.
- Qu'est ce qui ferait que
la COP 26 est un succès?
- La COP 26 est un succès
si on passe, en fait, des
objectifs domestiques vers
une compréhension collective de
limiter la hausse température à
1,5 degrés Celsius et qu'on se
donne ce mandat mondial de faire
de cet objectif-là une question
de justice sociale, d'équité,
de coopération et de
renforcement des objectifs
climatiques.
- On sait que le problème vient
de nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre. On sait qu'on doit
donc arrêter d'émettre. En 2018,
le rapport du GIEC disait qu'on
avait augmenté la température
mondiale d'un degré. On est en
2021. Le GIEC nous dit qu'on est
à 1,1 et on voit qu'en trois
ans, il y a eu une accélération
des bouleversements climatiques
à l'échelle de la planète.
On ne peut pas se permettre de
dépasser 1,5, donc c'est
maintenant que ça se joue.